ahora es un muy buen momento para que
comencemos a ver algunas de las
propiedades de la transformada de la
plaza la primera que les quiero mostrar
es digamos que quiero tomar la
transformada de la plaza
la suma de dos funciones que dependen de
t que está multiplicadas por una
constante s 1 por ft más otra constante
c 2 por g dt es una función de t
por definición la transformada de plas
nos dice que esto es igual a la integral
impropia de 0 a infinito
a la menos s t multiplicado lo que se
encuentra entre los corchetes
que en este caso ese 1 por ft
más de 2 por g de t
todo esto con dt y esto va a ser igual a
la integral impropia de 0 infinito
multiplicamos a la menos siete por los
términos que se encuentren aquí dentro
y separar esto de manera que nos quede
esta integral de 1 por la menos st efe
dt
más de dos a la - st jorge de t
todo esto dt
por la definición de las propiedades de
las integrales podemos separar estas dos
integrales o esta suma las como la suma
de estas integrales
así que esto va a ser igual a c1 que es
la constante la podemos sacar por la
integral de 0 infinito
a la sct por ft
dt más de dos por la integral impropia
de 0 a infinito de
al menos siete por siete de té
esta fue una forma muy larga de decir
que bueno estamos viendo que estas son
transformadas de la plaza es la
definición de la transformada de la
plaza de la plaza así que aquí podemos
decir que se uno por la transformada de
la plaza de ft
c2 por la transformada de la classe dgt
dt
así que hemos mostrado que una de las
propiedades de la transformada de la
plaza que la transformada de esta
función es que se suman es igual a las
sumadas o transformadas
eso es algo que es bastante útil para
cuando estamos trabajando con diferentes
funciones que vamos a transformar
ahora vamos a hacer otra cosa que yo
considero es aún mucho más interesante
pues esto nos va a dar una pista de por
qué las transformadas de la plaza son
tan tan útiles cuando trabajamos en
ecuaciones diferenciales digamos que
quiero encontrar la transformada de la
plaza hacemos la transformada de la
plaza de f prima de t
o sea tomamos la derivada de la función
t y le estamos sacando la transformada
de la plaza y aquí vamos a necesitar la
función
efe dt y su derivada f prima de t para
esto vamos a necesitar hacer uso de una
integral por partes una integración por
partes para desglosar esto
así que esto va a ser igual por la
definición a la integral impropia de
cero a infinito
a la menos st x es el primer dt
dt
y para resolver esto vamos a usar la
integración por partes
esto creo recordarlo porque luce en el
vídeo anterior creo que lo recuerdo pero
vamos a escribirlo aquí
integral de x prima que se parece a lo
que tenemos aquí va a ser igual a la
multiplicación de estas dos funciones
sin la derivada por b - la integral del
complemento o prima por b así que vemos
que aquí lo que vamos a sustituir está
bastante claro queremos terminar con una
f de t así que vamos a hacer b prima que
sea f prima de t y un igual a la menos
sdt así que aquí escribimos y iguala
al menos 7 y b va a ser igual
y va a ser igual a que era igual
efe dt así que ahora nuestra prima va a
ser igual a menos s por el ala menos st
y ahora nuestra prima está derribe prima
perdón de prima es igual a efe prima de
t así que va a ser igual a efe dt
disculpen esta equivocación pero bueno
esta es un
y esta otra es de prima aquí lo
señalamos y si ésta es mi prima este más
adelante derivada por lo que va a ser
efe nt y así que ahora sí vamos a
aplicar nuestra integración por partes
está transformada de la plaza que es
esto va a ser igual entonces a o por b
que es la menos 7
por ver que es nuestra ft
menos menos la integral aunque bueno
aquí tenemos que tener en cuenta que
vamos a evaluar todo esto
a 0 a infinito ahorita si quiero
mantener los límites porque no quiero
estar regresando o yendo y viniendo
entre integrales e indefinidas e
integrales impropias entonces va a ser
ahora sin menos la integral de 0 a
infinito de prima o prima es menos s x
- etc
por vez y nuestra vez ft
efe dt así que menos por menos es más
estos son más ésta es una constante así
que la podemos sacar así que todo esto
va a ser igual
al menos st efe dt evaluado de 0 a
infinito
s por la integral de cero al infinito
a la menos st efe dt vete y aquí vemos
esto qué es esto a pues es la
transformada de la plaza de ft así que
esto va a ser igual vamos a evaluar esto
de una vez
cuanto vale esto cuando usted se
aproxima infinito es la menos infinito
se aproxima a 0 y bueno aquí tenemos una
pregunta interesante
efe mtf de infinito pues no se puede ser
grande puede ser pequeña incluso podría
ser que se aproxime a algún valor
si esto se aproxima a cero si ésta se
incrementa más rápido que esta otra
entonces podría divergen no quiero
meterme en detalles matemáticos sobre si
esto convergió divergen pero digamos muy
en general que esto va a converger a
cero si ft crece más despacio que a la
menos siete se aproxima a cero quizás
más adelante podamos ver en qué
condiciones esta expresión podría
converger pero vamos a asumir que efe dt
crece un poquito más despacio que a la
menos cc.oo que converge más despacio
que a la menos etc o que crece más
despacio de lo que está se encoge por lo
que
si ésta crece más despacio de lo que
está decrece entonces va a tender a
hacer así que vamos a tener menos toda
esta expresión evaluada en 0 cuando ted
es igual a cero y al a menos cero es uno
fd 0 efe de 0 más s y dijimos que esta
es la transformada de la plaza de gente
así que es multiplicado por la
transformada de la plaza de f dt
vemos que tenemos una propiedad
interesante ya que la transforma de la
plaza de una función prima va a ser
vamos a escribirlo de nuevo aquí que en
otro color la transformada de la plaza
de f prima de t
va a ser igual a esta parte s
multiplicada por la transformada de la
plaza de ft
a menos
de 0
vamos a extender esto un poco más allá
que esto es algo bastante útil de saber
cuál es la transformada de la plaza de
la segunda derivada de ft
podemos ver que hay un patrón aquí va a
ser igual a ese multiplicado por la
transformada de la plaza delante y
derivada de lo que esté aquí que sería f
prima de t cierto
vemos que de aquí a acá se tiene una
anti derivada y de que acá también hay
una anti derivada - efe prima
de 0 ok bueno otra escuela se transforma
desde la plaza de esto
ah bueno esto va a ser igual a ese por
la transformada de la plaza df prima de
té que es a pues es esto así que va a
ser ese por la transformada de la plaza
de f dt
- efe de 0
esto sustituye nada más que hay aquí
aquí
- efe prima de 0
podemos tener al final que la
transformada de la segunda derivada de
ft es s cuadrada por la transformada de
la plaza df de t
- s por efe de 0 - efe prima de 0 aquí
vemos que está en un patrón y esta es la
transformada de laplace de la segunda
derivada de ft
y aquí podemos ver porque su tierra
transformada de la plaza transformada
derivadas en multiplicaciones y veremos
más adelante que transforma integrales
en divisiones y pueden tomar derivadas
arbitrarias y van a terminar con una
serie de multiplicaciones por s y se me
está acabando el tiempo pero les voy a
dejar de tarea que ustedes hagan la
transformada de la plaza de la tercera
derivada de f dt